hey guys it's me again
I'm going to talk about my massage tool
this is an incredible tool that you can
apply to your body to extract stress it
comes with this little booklet and in
this book I show you step-by-step how to
apply this to your body to pull out most
of the stress and your body in a very
short period of time I use this
faithfully before I go to bed on my body
and my wife's like are you using that
thing again I said yes because it
I designed it for myself actually and
it's designed by my hand there's three
different positions for three different
sizes of people and I just simply read
the book
apply it exactly like I'm talking about
maybe 5-10 minutes before you go to bed
and you will feel the difference you can
use it on a tall back chair or a couch
but this basically is for extracting
stress especially for sleep pain and
just overall health and I also gave you
some tips in here about how to get rid
of other types of pain as well
low back pain and some other things so
go ahead and start using this walk
through this and on the back of here you
can go to this website and watch the
videos of how to use this okay
the main one that you want to use is the
one on the neck and the adrenals
everything else could be like extra okay
but definitely the one you'll see it on
the upper neck and then on your abdomen
area right here so go ahead apply those
techniques and the one on the abdomen is
called the fascial points facha because
the fascia is a little sheath around the
abdomen that tends to hold and support
the organs but it's a point of a it's I
could hold stress as well so you're
going to do those points and go ahead
and apply this and I think you're really
going to like it